foreign
musical instruments that were almost
lost during World War II are not only
being recovered and repaired they're
teaching lessons from the past in the
universal language here's Manuel
bojorkas
[Music]
I am in New Orleans
among the exhibits and artifacts
visitors were drawn to an unexpected
site
foreign
violins so this one was played in
Auschwitz they belonged to Jewish
victims and survivors of the Holocaust
laid silent until they were given New
Life in a Tel Aviv Workshop by abshalom
Weinstein and his father amnon we are
preparing and restoring all these
instruments because we think it's
important for the people to hear the
sound of what those people heard
during the war for Weinstein it's
personal his grandparents lost nearly
their entire family in the Holocaust
still his grandfather a violin repairman
in Israel started to save what no one
wanted German made instruments why did
he take them in because my grandfather
didn't want to see the instruments being
broken destroyed or lost
The Collection has grown to more than
100 through their program violins of
Hope the instruments are exhibited and
played at concerts all over the world
reclaiming them from their dark past
so what do we have here so here we have
one of the instruments which belong to
the bernheim family they had a very big
convenience store which had the first
elevator in the town and they had very
good life in Germany
of course once the Nazis came into power
it was basically impossible for them to
keep on the business prosperous
shopkeepers Alfred and Berta bernheim
fled their small German Town after being
terrorized by the Nazis they were
marched in the town naked
in all the citizens were throwing stuff
on them while they were marching in the
main Boulevard naked others in
concentration camp orchestras were
ordered to play as their fellow Jews
were sent to their deaths I'm going to
tell you in very few words about
the violin from our collection that
you'll hear tonight on this night a
restored violin will sing once again
concert by the Louisiana Philharmonic
Orchestra
world-renowned violinist Philippe Quint
played it for a few precious moments
[Music]
foreign
it's really an incredible vehicle that
transforms you into
sends you into a different time
a time when members of his family were
among the 6 million Jews killed
it is our responsibility to carry on the
memory and to pass it on to the next
Generations
on stage the past merges with the
present
so in this way
some of these victims live on
their name lives on their story lives on
and hopefully the message of don't
forget that we are all human beings
still resonates somehow
[Music]
Saturday morning and while bojorquez New
Orleans
beautiful yeah I can't hear the music
from Schindler's List without it
bringing tears to my eyes I think it is
so important in a time where we're
seeing a rise in anti-Semitism to have
something tangible that somebody can see
and hold and touch potentially or at
least hear and have that backstory so
that there is that tie to the Past also
and so important never to forget that
man's inhumanity man still exists and we
can't forget it we can never forget that
we never forget